ça fait trente ans que je travaille dans
les soins j'ai sacrifié ma famille pour
ce boulot la profession a changé on n'a
plus besoin de pilotes de sous marins
ils veulent que vous débarrasser votre
bureau aujourd'hui je crois que je
connais un moyen de me sortir de la
merde et nous faire du fric
un sous-marin asie est en train de
rouiller au fond de la mer noire
rempli de lingots d'or
de combien de hauts responsables 182
millions de dollars
on partage à parts égales pas trop on
est prêt fermeture je trouve ça
dégueulasse qui touche autant
va ton avis qu'est ce qu'ils feront ils
se rendront compte que leur part
augmentent s'il ya moins de monde qui
partageait 5 4
gravity
et un par un
hu
à l'écouter sans fin